is that the same answer well as long as
you're not hurting the animals I'm also
in favor of animal rights and again I
mean excuse me for going over time but
since you are adding to the question
here they that the question here has I
mean you can argue based on principle
but you can also argue as mr. Hobart
your job is done based on empirical
realities and then the question becomes
how how many people does this involve
what is the problem here
how large is the problem why should we
have laws against something that I mean
a very small minority and I would like
to see the statistics on how many
Norwegians are traveling to Denmark to
have sex with animals and what animals
by the way I mean this becomes sort of
absurd discussion thank you so I will
take one question to Mohammed a job this
actually it feels like it's a follow-up
question the individual is asking how
does Islam regard these kinds of matters
sexual relationships with the same
gender and with animals and why do you
believe that that that your moral views
are correct first of all I find it quite
interesting that I find amputation of
hands disgusting but when we're talking
about having sex with dogs and cats and
horses this is not something that maybe
makes you feel disgusted the problem is
he said you'd have to see the dog or
whatever animal it is a motion visitor
is harmed or how can a dog consent when
they can't even speak has he been in a
balk how's it going to say house
seriously I want to have sex with you
dog how to talks for yes and one one
part for how are you gonna know I mean
this is really this is the absurdity of
consent theory and liberalism you know
seriously I mean where do we draw the
line
and frankly this shows you how much
liberalism and human rights are
creatures of convention they are
subjective they are baseless they're
just basically what white people sorry
to say what why people find ok what
white people find tasty or for the
sensibilities of the white people that's
what literally sorry to say that is
liberalism in a nutshell since it white
man's not even woman for the most part
white man's sensibilities subjective
preferences yeah it's ok for a brother
and sister to have sex but cutting the
hand of the thief I mean who who's made
this the parameters the correct
parameters for us it's a straightforward
thing and when I say white man I'm not
meaning that the rug rhetorically I'm
meaning that quite physically in the
sense that the 1948 convention of human
rights the ones who had the ha the
biggest say in that were American white
men because America emerges as a
superpower and it was in charge of those
particular institutions and still is
disproportionately considering the size
of China and Russia by the way and
there's lots of literature on that I'm
sure he's aware so when we say the New
World Order and the white man is in
control of the basically the Preferences
that we'd the rest of the world we
should be shaped in the image and the
mold of the white man post enlightenment
experience this is the reality so you
can have sex with the dog potentially
right he didn't want to really say it
you can have sex with your mum and your
dad sorry children I here or your
brother or your sister can have enjoy
your time freedom but you know this
thing about cutting the hand I don't
know about that it's disgusting oh he's
giving us the I mean to be honest it's
like I eat this I drink that it's all a
matter of taste now it's become bit
ridiculous cut force your tastes on me
I like Somali food you might like Viking
food you might like Norwegian I don't
know what they eat him you can't tell me
you have to eat the sausage and this egg
and I don't find that nice we say the
more Jack
or the one who finally determines which
is acceptable moral recourse and what is
not acceptable to answer the question is
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala is God
Almighty and we have good reason
believe God's exists God exists we have
good reason to believe the Prophet
Muhammad is is the actual final prophet
he gives evidences for that and so
divine command theory would suggest that
whatever comes from this is eternally
true which by the way can adjust in
terms of time and place but that's part
of the eternally true mechanism and
that's how we live our lives sexual
matters financial matters and so on and
so forth like I said if you want
guidance you have to seek guidance from
the one who knows what guidance which we
believe is